oh hang on we got here
a guy in death settlement in the u.s
this will be interesting so jacob let's
let's throw jacob in because this is
something i know like the back of my
hand what's up dude
hey how's it going rich thank you so
much yeah
do you want to tell me which company you
work for yeah sure why not uh i work for
a freedom debt relief
oh okay andrew hauser's a friend of mine
oh yeah he's a good guy
i like him yeah i i specifically work in
the uh the consolidation loan
uh division okay yeah that's great
yeah it's um i started out as one of
those uh middle of the mall kiosk
hustlers
i went through a uh a very uh tragic
breakup
that's when i kind of woke up and i
wanted to win this girl back
and i uh these guys were at freedom they
gave me a chance
okay so that's how i got here but are
you in uh
san san what is the town name san mateo
i think was where their head office was
that's yeah the the head office is in
california but i'm here in uh um tempe
arizona
okay you're in the arizona spot okay
cool so what's your question
my question is um you know i just worry
with the
um political climate how progressive
things are becoming
uh here in the states you know do you
think debt settlement this industry is
going to last
um why do you think it's not going to
last so let's start with that
uh i'm a that that's a good question um
the from from what i can see from what
i'm sensing from these politicians
uh the left the democrats they're all
about
um you know raising the standards of
living up
and uh forgiving the mistakes of us
yeah yeah ubi so on and so forth and i
get the sense that they're not really
wanting to hold
uh people accountable and especially in
regards to debts
student loans that and uh it worries me
because that's that's my industry so
you know it's uh what what can
potentially happen when people
aren't held accountable for their uh
financial mistakes
um you know
do you feel what i'm saying no i get it
like that's a great question and
and there's and there's two sides to
this one coin so on the one side of the
coin
you've got um the politicians
who want more votes and they realize
that
the more people they can have sucking
off the teat of the state
reliant on that for a source of income
and
for their standard of living and for
their core happiness
the better off they're going to be so
they're basically selling long-term
misery
you know which is which is cloaked in
disguise you know how
non-profit credit counselors are often
called uh
kinder friendlier collection agencies to
the banks
yes right that's that's kind of what the
government is right like they're trying
to be kinder friendlier
um and you know supportive to society
but
it's [ __ ] that's that's not what
they are kind of like the nonprofit
credit counselors are not what they're
selling people
so the problem is is people are stupid
like the average iq is lower than 100
right like people aren't bright
and if you know the government says
here's some free [ __ ] take it
and be like okay we'll take that like
people in the us they don't want freedom
they don't want sovereignty what what
they want is they want free [ __ ]
right so they're going to keep voting
for more policies to do that so
let's uh forgive debt let's let's lower
interest rates let's you know
give away free [ __ ] that's right now the
problem with that is that the world runs
on
money so we on the other side of the
coin you've got the financial
institutions
who make a [ __ ] ton of money off
interest
um i've i've been in the business for a
long long time as you know
and i was an insider in the collection
industry um
for almost as long as well and
it's it's mind-boggling how much money
they make of
service interest payments on debt and
how long it keeps people
in debt they make so much profit it is
ridiculous now are they going to give
that up
i don't think so they're going to go
down kicking and screaming so
there's going to have to be a happy
compromise somewhere in the middle
do i think that the debt relief industry
is a good place to be for a young guy
today
i'm going to say no and i own one of
those businesses
now now why do you say that
what's the big bright future right like
how are you going to put a dent in the
universe
coloring within the lines crossing the
t's and dotting the eyes for
you know this this industry which is
which has found a way to get people out
of debt which by the way
over time is harder and harder to
execute
there's more and more regulations the
same thing here in canada there's more
and more
regulations and there's there's
very high penalties if the process is
not executed properly right
i mean you're always walking this fine
line like it always felt like you're on
this tight rope
you know in this industry and i'm sure
you know the guys like andrew and brad
you know feel the same way still
but i'm not in the state so i don't have
all the insider
details today you know to be on be on
the up and up but i would say you know
as a general
rule find something else to do dude
so yeah and i can appreciate that
response you know i went from as i
mentioned here earlier i went from work
in the middle of the mall to um
you know living with a roommate uh just
turned 25.
okay so what do you want to do with your
life like where do you see yourself at
35 let's say
i want to make money i want to be in
control of something of my own
that feeling is within me okay um
you know doing what i'm not sure i had
skills growing up that
you know perhaps i could utilize i was
always real good at graphic design
i was always very very comfortable in
front of people that's how i got into
sales but
uh bus i want to own a business i want
to be running something
but i'm not sure what it would be just
yet okay well you have to start moving
towards that if you want to hit that by
35 because
more often than not nine times out of 10
of business is gonna fail
so if you go by the stats you're
probably gonna have to start up 10
businesses for
one success and you're going to need a
good one to two year run to
to to figure out if the business is
going to be successful or not
so if you you know so if you start to
look at the math it could take you
you know on a good run 10 years
on a shitty run maybe 20 years to figure
it out right you know for you to get to
that point
depending on how successful you are how
much help you have along the way how
much luck you know
comes your way you know there's a whole
bunch of factors to look at you know how
how well-honed your decision-making
skills are
there's a lot really you know to look at
there and unpack but you're not going to
achieve that goal
you know working for somebody else
yeah and again you know
i talked to the guy earlier what was his
name adam from jordan
high ticket sales you know you're
selling jet planes yachts sailboats
rolls-royce
you're a c-suite you know job right
cto cfo ceo
stem something that pays big and stem
obviously
entrepreneur is big too and there's
other professional
you know designations like lawyer doctor
you know account you know stuff like
that but those would be the main ones
like if you really want to put a dent to
the universe and you want to have a big
bright future for yourself
you're going to have to start looking
into moving in that direction and
getting out of what you're doing you
know in the day-to-day job because
you know um who was it that said it i
think it was kevin o'leary that said
something like
you know the most addictive thing that
they give people is a salary
you know like a bi-weekly salary because
it makes you give up your hopes and
dreams
yeah now i i do have another question um
uh do you mind if i ask another question
sure one more
yeah um real real quick i um i'm at the
i feel like i'm at this uh
this transition point my life where i'm
giving up a lot of uh interest passions
i had growing up
that i was very very much uh obsessed
with
why why are you giving them out because
i don't feel like they make money
i don't care they provide a solution for
enough people to
give me the lifestyle and uh you know
fulfill that part of me
that why don't they make you money like
what are the passions what are we
talking about here
uh uh growing up i it was uh i was
constantly doing art
graphic design drawing i mean from
i mean as long as i remember from when i
was a little kid all the way up until
high school i was going to go to school
for graphic design but i i chose not to
simply because i don't feel like the
money's there and i don't
know of a way that i could you know
make you know seven figures drawing
it just seems like an absolute dream to
me i mean unless i was going to some
sort of pie art form
well i mean there's like i watched a
video on alex becker's channel the other
day and he [ __ ] sold a
red square on it you know as an nft for
like i don't know 200 bucks or something
like it was literally
a square that was colored in red right
so there so there's some weird [ __ ]
selling you know in in art as nfts
in some cases for millions right so
it's not like you can't make money at it
but it but like the long
like the long and short of it really is
is there's not a lot of really
wealthy artists out there i mean you're
an artistic guy i get it
you know you're good at it you like it
it's something that you probably lose
track of time when you do
the [ __ ] that i like that doesn't make
money like i like
uh i don't know like you know the art of
bonsai for me is [ __ ] interesting
you know yeah i used to like racing cars
but there's no money in racing like
i found out you know when i got deep
enough into racing and
i worked as a uh
part of a pit crew at mossport here for
two races once and i'm like
you know like i wanted to get the inside
scoop and i'm like so
you know what kind of money is made in
this and where does it go and
you know how do you raise sponsors and
it's like there's no money in racing
like most guys that race do it as a
[ __ ] passion just because they like
going fast
actually most guys that race cars are
entrepreneurs
that have enough money to blow that they
sponsor their own race car
ah okay so and to clarify my question
i worry sometimes that perhaps it's too
late to
find a new skill to master and
you're 25 man you got no
you got lots of time no but is it okay
okay you got lots of time don't even
don't even talk like
like i'm in my late 40s and i started
doing this only a few years ago like
this was a new skill for me right like
you know it's it's it's it's outside of
my normal comfort zone with
what i'm an expert at like i know the
credit and collection industry like the
back of my hand
right like i know a lot of people in the
industry like i know the people that
started up your company right like i
know a lot of people
in the united states that run in the
debt settlement space
and even creditors too and law firms and
guys that you know we're lobbyists and
all that sort of stuff
it's not what i want to do though right
this is this is a new skill that i've
learned so don't say that you can't
learn a new skill at 25. that's that's
[ __ ] man you got you got lots of
runway ahead of you the problem is is
don't [ __ ] waste it
right because because if you let five 10
years burn and you're like
all right i'm 35 what have i done with
my life you're gonna be [ __ ]
right because you just burned through 10
years you'll never get time back you can
always make money back you know you can
go and spend money on something and [ __ ]
it up and have it flop like i've
i've thrown money at some businesses
i've you know thrown money at some
crypto i've thrown some money in some
stocks
and it's gone nowhere you know it's just
poof it's just evaporated
it doesn't matter right i i
may have spent fifty thousand dollars
learning that lesson
it was a fifty thousand dollar education
but i'll never make that same mistake
again but i still have the time because
i was efficient with it
see what i'm saying yeah i see what
you're saying rich i appreciate the
guidance
all right tell andrew i said hi i will
sure
see you man peace
you